this is a production of cornell
university
uh today's seminar is an experiment
our graduate students
requested that we go to a more
casual format to foster
community spirit so we've turned
today's uh
time slot over to them
take it away tristan
thanks gillian i'm gonna share my screen
gillian's right today is a trial of a
very discussion based
and hopefully lively this uh lively
seminar
so good afternoon everyone i'm glad to
see that there are so many people online
today
this is our first plant pathology
luncheon
this is a fun and enjoyable time where
we can have a lively discussion on a
variety of topics
so since the start of the pandemic we've
noticed that
there are that many of our traditional
ways of casual interactions
our coffee breaks social events
general hallway talk have been reduced
or stopped altogether
and our goal is to help recreate these
casual spaces
or folks in plant pathology to talk and
share their ideas
not unlike a conversation
these conversations would be typically
centered around
but it's not limited to topics are
presented on
and we think this is one way we can
increase our community engagement
we treat this as a very casual and fun
seminar
so how do these luncheons work
unlike typical presentations don't be
afraid to ask questions
make comments or respond to comments in
the chat
during the presentation treat the chat
like you would a form
alternatively you can also raise your
hand and share your ideas verbally
i can give a short pause after each idea
or slide to help
and lastly we want to remind you that
this is our first time trying something
of a more interactive seminar format
and we are seeing these kinds of lunches
to be a good addition to our section so
we appreciate your patience
and we encourage you to engage and
talk i am also aware that other
departments at cornell
and other institutions have a similar a
lot of time when departments come
together
and talk about subjects ranging from
research projects to imposter syndrome
to other random experiences and
encounters
if there's something that you think
would be a helpful change in this format
love to hear from you
in the spirit of community engagement i
like to define what community is
a group of people connected by interests
values or goals that communicate
with and relate to one another
there is no requirement for all of us to
be in the same room or building
so by this definition we can see that we
can still maintain a community
while still socially distancing
especially with technology today
community just looks different
and with every week being uncertainty
relationships and community have the
power to bring support and reliability
into our daily lives
in 2012 the new york times published an
article called
why is it hard to make friends over 30.
our situation being in a pandemic is
obviously more complex than simply
making friends
but i believe that the efforts of what
we put into maintaining long-lasting
friendships
is transferable to maintain a robust
community
the topic is timeless such so that the
new york times actually ran the same
piece again
several years later
in the piece the article talks about the
difficulty and maintain
friendships and the conditions that
sociologists have said are important
for maintaining close relations close
relations
those three elements are repeated on
planet interactions
proximity and settings that allow people
to let their guard down and confide in
one in each other
these are elements that can be hard to
come by right now we may not be living
close to each other
but sometimes it doesn't feel that way
and i'm sure most reversal interactions
are not
are in a very much planned informal
format
and this is why i think it is a good
idea to remind ourselves the importance
of keeping in touch outside
former meetings
casual conversation is a good venue for
coming up with new ideas
building trust and taking a step from
being just co-workers
to being community members
i remember once running into mary
mccullar on the third floor
who was decked out in her magical
mushroom uniform
hurting students the hostorium to try
delicious corn smut
and i think we were remarking about how
delightful it was to see adventurous
students try cornsmut
seeing students to try seeing students
encourage to try something
outside their comfort zone and it really
inspired me and i remember lugging a
bowl of leftover cornstarch to my
friends across campus you've never even
heard of smut before
and that bull eventually made its way to
a professor in engineering who
absolutely loved it
this was obviously before free code
sanitation standards
and this entire experience of sharing
made me
genuinely feel like i was a part of a
greater internet interconnected
community
and it started with just a happenstance
hallway conversation with mary
i've seen great examples of faculty
staff and students
and friends supporting each other
intersection and i don't see that
changing anytime soon
our community is rich and vibrant and
dependable
and i also want to put in the plug-in
so that so that if you want to set the
topic for our next luncheon
which can be on anything research or not
we would love to hear from you
and with that i'll love to transition
over to
a good friend and fellow graduate
student juliana
thank you tristan can you hear me well
absolutely
perfect so i'll share my screen uh but
first i'd like to
say hi to everyone i'm super honored
that i'm
kicking off these semesters seminars i
had no idea this was ever going to
happen to me
so i'm happy to be here and also i'm
very happy to be part of this new
initiative
that the gsa designed for all of us
so can you see my screen right now
yes we can perfect so um well
when tristan and tori reached out to me
they said that they were interesting in
talking a little bit about you know
science community communication um
especially right now during the pandemic
and i'll explain to you all in a second
why i had
like a recent experience related to this
um
and that's why i'm here today and this
is very relaxed i have some
interactive slides i hope they work if
they
don't work we can just use the chat but
just as tristan said feel free to
interrupt me
um you know write down oops it changed
in the chat i'm not sure if i'll be able
to see it but tristan can help me with
that if you
write some things during the
presentation and just to stop
or you know talk in a very relaxed
matter
uh so i decided to pick up this title
communication communicating science it's
not only about the message
for all of you that don't know me my
name is juliana i am a second year phd
grad student uh on melanie phillips
church slav
i usually work with dkia de dante and
you know
small rnas and other things related to
that fascinating
pathogen but today we're not going to
talk about research
we're going to talk about something
different um
so to start off you all know
you know this pandemic right so this
actually is a picture of cornell
health and these are just two other
pictures that i found online
related to the pandemic but i recently
came like more aware that there's
another pandemic
that's um you know burdening us all
and that's what people have started to
call an emphademic
at first they was not very familiar with
the term
but perhaps you could have come across
it recently
and i was doing a little bit of research
about it and it seems like it has been
around since 2003.
um david vrodkov in the washington post
published uh um yeah i think it was an
editorial back then
talking actually about the sars virus
not so not the stars cup does
the cup 2 but the original stars that we
knew around 2003
uh and he was talking about these new
situation where people were receiving so
much information regarding
a disease that could be you know very
bad for them and their families
and that was beginning to make it harder
to actually control
a public health crisis just because
everybody was receiving so much
information and was getting confused and
like
uh you know confusion leads to fear
and then when you are afraid of
something you cannot deal with it
correctly
so that happened in 2003 and i guess it
has been around
also in some other things but it was not
very
noticeable until recently last year
um the director of who mentioned it
again
at a press conference of course talking
about kobe 19 this
time um he said we're not just fighting
an epidemic we're fighting an empademic
um so it has been sort of renewed or its
use had
have been changed right now and people
are using it a lot to refer to this
outstanding amount of information that
we're all receiving
like in the news social media or just
like talking with each other
i don't know if you have this some
experience but at least at the beginning
when i was jumping into zoom calls with
friends that were supposed
to be like you know relaxing scenarios
sometimes it turned to be like everybody
was just talking about what's happening
right now
and that's logical because that's
something that we're all feeling
and we're all living um
so i was when i was preparing these
slides i decided to use google trends to
sort of get an idea of
how much the terms vaccines or kovic 19
vaccine
have been googled in the last year and
as you see here
uh you know when we get closer and
closer to 2021
both terms start peaking up and this is
just the same example in spanish
and you'll see why i did it in spanish
as well in a second
um so it looks like late december early
you know february and right now
of course we're having this peak of
people trying to
to read about these topics on google
because it's the moment where you know
it was
advertised and it was in the news that
pfizer and moderna
got their vaccines out there and you
know started vaccinating people
uh this is just a distribution of like
the countries where the
different terms are researched more
um so i found two things interesting
from this exercise
first what i was telling you like this
there's this peak
around the end of the year early 2021
and then also if you compare both terms
in english
people are looking more for the specific
coding and team vaccine
well if you search for the same terms
just translated to spanish
people are usually just looking for the
term vaccines
more than they are looking for coping
and team vaccine and i found that
interesting and i'll explain why in a
second
based on the recent experience that i've
had
so i started feeling this search
of information related to the vaccines
as i said in december and january
um but in order to explain what happened
to me i just wanted to say a little bit
more about me so that you can understand
the whole context
so for those of you who don't know i'm
originally from colombia
which is here uh this is just a picture
of bogota
the city where i was born and lived all
my life before i came here
um and in my specific case i have a very
big family
so both on my mom's side and on my dad's
side
i have a lot of calls and cousins well
and i know this is not that common maybe
here in the us
but in colombia and in other latin
american countries
people really use whatsapp the the
cell phone app as a texting you know
app they don't really send text messages
rather they just use the app
uh much more than i have seen people
using it here
and it has happened during the whole
pandemic but mostly
end of 2020 early 2021 that people have
been sending
chains of messages so it's like this
message had to build up
you send that and if people find it
interesting they will forward it
to their context and this became
fake news chains in most parts so i'm
just like i found some
examples here they're all in spanish and
my intention is not for you to
understand all of it but
just see the amount of information that
can be
rotating in people's phones that they're
receiving
from you know their family their friends
in these whatsapp groups of like
50 people where the whole family is
there so grandma aunts
cousins everybody's there they're
sharing information
that is not most cases it's not
scientifically correct
and even in some cases it can be
dangerous
both related to the vaccines and also
related to things that people can drink
or you know telling people to drink
different things to deal with the virus
and things like that so at first i was
trying to ignore this just because i was
like
it makes no sense but then i started
realizing that my family was
actually believing it and that some of
them were even taking actions towards
that so either
not wanting to get vaccine without you
know real information about it or
drinking things that they shouldn't
drink
to control the virus
and that really struck me because i will
go to this poll in a second because
i was usually just bombarded with
scientific information while they were
being bombarded with
social media information or fake news
information so before we continue with
this story i
i designed this poll i hope it works you
could either vote in
the link or you can text this
first to get like get inside the poll
and then send
the response i would just like to know
how frequently do
are you receiving information about the
kobe 19 vaccines via social media so
i was talking about whatsapp but there's
also facebook instagram twitter
all of this um i will be interested in
seeing
if i'm seeing a similar pattern i'm on
this group that we have here
as the one i've been feeling so tristan
are you able to vote
oh yeah somebody is voting perfect yay
okay i'll just give a couple of seconds
to see what happens
um
but yeah definitely for me it has been i
will say i will vote more than once per
day
um but that might be because i have
different social media accounts but
anyway if i just had one it will
probably be also more than once per day
okay well this seems good so
for people that have voted until now we
are all receiving once per day or even
more than once per day
now i'm just going to
leave you a second in this slide while i
activate the next
question so that it works out
as well let me go
back to the presentation
oops okay can you see this one right now
yep
yep i hope it works i just activate it
has this information affected your
decision on whether to get vaccine or
not
oh yep it works perfect okay so we have
no we'll just wait a couple of seconds
yep okay and this can be you know like
either side like i didn't want to get it
now i'm getting it
or i wanted to get it and now i'm not
getting it i just want to see how much
the this type of information impacts
people decisions
okay good so it looks like most
of the cases it's not impacting the
decision but in some of them are
and this is exactly the same trend i was
seeing
either you know with my family and when
i was reaching out to close friends
so let me see if i can change to the
next
slide oops here this one
okay so now finally after all this story
why i'm talking to you today
as i was saying i had been receiving
scientific information but i noticed
that my family and friends were
receiving other type of information
and that type of information that they
were receiving sometimes
made facts change into myths
or made the information less clear for
them
so i have a little bit of experience in
scientific communication
i was just wanted to remembering morgan
and andrea
morgan as you'll remember she was super
involved in programs as a skype a
scientist
where you talk to kids from different
schools and then during the pandemic
they were even doing it with families
about science about you know your
expertise
um and then with andrea we both work in
women in a science which is a
coalition uh to promote literally women
that work in the agricultural sciences
and to like
uplift each other and just communicate
these type of topics to a general public
so i had a little bit of expertise but i
was not you know expertise in talking
about kobe or the vaccines so i decided
to
record a video it was an eight-minute
video in spanish
just for my family and my friends
explaining the things that i thought
were most important about the rna coping
vaccines
especially because you know this is a
new technology for
you know the general public and it has
elicited so many myths and lies
uh relating to it but you know how how
sometimes
internet works and video went viral in
colombia and some other latin american
countries
this is the instagram one but it was
similar in twitter and facebook
and i was like what is going on
so it was a good experience and i could
you know talk with so many different
groups about it but anyway it was like
just making me realize how much people
are lacking information at least in
spanish
uh that comes from a trustworthy source
like
not me but just like the cdc or who or
things like that
and i'm just like a bridge translating
that
to a more approachable language for
everybody
so this made me think how
successful are fake news like is this
really a thing
and i found two i'm not going to share a
lot of data but i found two
articles that i found interesting this
is from 2018
it was published in science and they
found that
fake news are being uh replicated in
social media almost like six times
faster
than real you know like truthful news
um and then they conclude that the
reason why
well they hypothesized that they there
might be two reasons why this is said
one being like fake news seem more novel
than truthful news they just like seem
more exciting in a sense
uh and then also fake news for the way
they are written or the language that
they're using
sometimes they are eliciting feelings
on the public that are more intense
than the ones that you know truthful
news can elicit
so people feel more even and i mean if
it's excitement or if it's anger if it's
fear and that feeling makes them want
to share that and that's why probably it
has been disseminating so fast
and then this other paper uh this was
more recent in 2020
this was about facebook at the beginning
of the pandemic
and they found out that 98 million
pieces of information
were actually misinformation that had
been on facebook for almost
the first year of the pandemic yeah like
the first months
um and at the end i mean after this
study was published facebook had to
take down all this information that was
available there for people to get
you know scared and confused about the
topic
so give me a second don't vote yet i
have to activate that one as well
but before we go to the last part of the
talk and then we can just start you know
discussing this if somebody wants to
speak up
um i wanted to see
how many of you have been trying or
wanting or needing
just how many of you have felt the
necessity to explain the science of
these vaccines to close
ones okay so we have some
boats for my family a lot of boats for
family and friends
and some of you that haven't felt this
need which is also good
in some conversations that i've had with
my friends from the united states
i've realized that maybe the information
here is much more approachable in
english than it is in spanish and that
could also be
a reason why uh some of you don't really
need
the you know feeling the need to explain
them because maybe your family already
understands how they work and they have
enough information to make an informed
decision
about getting the vaccine or not okay
but it looks like most of you
do feel the need or have been feeling
the need to talk to family and friends
about this and i know this is hard
uh i know sometimes we want to explain
our science not even the vaccines but
the other things we do in a approachable
language
and that becomes hard uh the slight you
know doubts in our voice or just like
using concepts that are a little bit out
of the people's normal language could
literally lead them to not believe in us
or not want to
listen to us anymore so with all this in
mind and with the things that i've
learned
during this month since that video was
out
um i decided to pick up five things that
i think are really important or have
been important for me
and maybe it will help you that are
trying to communicate these type of
topics to your family so the first thing
that i was going to mention and i
already sort of
uh skim throughout is the language
barrier
when i was starting to explain this to
my family i found that the most
uh useful information and clear
information out there
was in english and i was able to
understand that and then communicate
that in a different language to my
family and friends but that's not
necessarily the case for everybody
um this is just an example of how the
cdc and
the fda's fac uh webpages look like
it's super accessible and you can just
go and see oh you know does this vaccine
change my dna
no and then explains in a very short way
why
uh but that's not exactly the same in
spanish and i've seen
you know twitter like other languages
people have been trying to translate
this type of information to their own
native language so that they can make it
more approachable to their own families
and their own communities back home
this is just an example of the types of
things that colombia started to do
very recently so this was january 15
and this was i think like last week so i
guess
after you know in part after my video
came out
and some other science communicators
started talking about this in colombia
then the official
entities started to produce a more
approachable thing
than it was before but even now it's not
absolutely approachable as it is
here in some cases uh then i found this
paper that i thought was interesting as
well this is not a paper this is a news
article they were talking about the
language barriers that can add a
problem when taking care of copied
patients that do not speak english
or vaccinating people here in the us
that do not speak english
and i know this not exactly refers to
the same that i was telling because it's
more
focused to people that are living in an
english-speaking country as the united
states
but it does reflect this huge problem
and this like huge delay of
information in different languages that
are not english
and that's why you know this whole other
world outside of the united states
probably is going to take much more
longer well and also the united kingdom
it's probably going to take much more
longer to get all their population or
most of their population vaccinated if
there's not
adequate information out there i don't
know if you have seen this example but
in israel
in israel they're almost done i think
with vaccinating most of the first
phase people because they did like these
um info
graphics and like short clips that they
played on national television
in their own language every night months
before the vaccines even arrived
just educating people for that when the
vaccines did arrive they were prepared
to make a decision
and then the last thing of this part is
like even when something is in your own
language that doesn't mean that you may
understand it completely um and that
relates me back to us briefly mentioning
about the terminology that you use to
talk about this to your family or to
your friends
uh even the terms that seem easiest to
us can completely confuse a person
that's
outside of you know a scientific
nucleus of people so for example with
the
messenger rna vaccines we have several
terms
that are not common for most people so
um you know nano particles or lipids
or even rna and dna i found
a lot of people at least back in
colombia being like i have no idea what
that means like i have an idea but i
cannot explain it
or understand it fully to people so what
i found
useful and you can use this too when
explaining it to your family and friends
is just look for something that's common
for them in their real life
that can explain as an analogy what
you're referring to
so for example when i was talking about
proteins um
i was you know leading to talk about the
spike protein that
vaccines um are targeting then
i just said you know proteins are just
like bricks that build our body up
so we need all these bricks for our
functions they make up our hair they
make up our skin
things like that or for example when i
was trying to explain
why lipid nanoparticles are included in
the vaccine
um i try to say you know they're like
vehicles
for the rna so they're like you have to
put it inside something
otherwise it will just degrade so it's
like part of the idea is to protect it
and move it safely from one place to
another
um and then i think this was the one
that helped people maybe most
when i was trying to explain what the
dna is and what rna
is what i was saying is like imagine you
are doing a recipe so you're
on your kitchen and you're trying to
make a dessert for example
so then you can think of the dna as sort
of your recipe book
but then you are going to build just one
of those desserts so
analogy you're just going to have one
protein produced
uh but you cannot just read the rece the
recipe and make the dessert you have to
read the recipe
trans like transcript that into a
different paper and then from that paper
you make the dessert
i was trying to explain that that paper
that like transition
would be what the messenger rna is doing
for us in this
specific case so of course i know like
if you think of the cheap science on it
i'm leaving so many things outside but
sometimes people just need a very clear
example of how the process works and
how that translates into what the
vaccine does
in their bodies um and then for the
another thing that i found very
interesting is that it's hard when
people are not trusting the message
per se so it's different to talk about
things that are maybe
less like hot topics right now
but right now talking about the vaccines
it's a super hot topic and it has a lot
of distrust
i found these um data when i was
preparing the slice this is from here
from the us
and it's i think it's it's good because
it's telling us that
um after december and after all these
infographics and all this information
start to go out to people um most
there's a bigger a proportion of people
that want to get vaccinated or will get
vaccinated as soon as they can
but you know there's also always people
that are not getting it and that
it's i think that's respectable if
they're taking that decision
in an informed way so if they're not
basing their decision on fake news
but rather on the real information
they're just deciding not to do it
and this is in spanish so i'm just going
to quickly point out the things that are
important
a similar uh you know poll was made in
colombia and they asked people
um if they were going together or not
and if not
well why would it be the reason and the
biggest amount said that they would not
get it because they're afraid of
very dangerous potential side effects uh
and all these very dangerous potential
side effects that they have been seeing
you know social media whatsapp things
like that telling them that they will
get their dna altered or that they would
get really really sick
or you know things like that so this is
important when you're trying to
communicate
something related to science to people
from the general public but
specifically right now take into account
that the message per se
might be distrusted and it's not you
it's just the message so you have to
make an extra effort
to make that seem more easy to
communicate
and i was thinking like even in other
topics that are
a little bit controversial so talking
about crispr and you know editing
genomes
all the ethical uh things that could be
behind that
talking about gmos which is a little bit
even more closer to what we do
and then climate change so there are a
lot of things that are very hot topic
right now and that you might feel
the need or you know uh want to talk
about that
with your friends and family so always
remember that since the topics have
these like pre um place
uh distrust on them you have to like
even be like the deal makers who i
thought about it like
even if the message is a little bit
conflicting if you are a good
communicator and you
inspire trust then you can sort of like
change the balance um on whether people
are trusting the message or not or where
the people
want to listen you and the message or
not
and that took me like how much trust in
the messengers that are telling these
messages so i have different messengers
here
um this is fauci you all know maybe you
don't not
maybe not all of you know her this is dr
kisi corvette
she's the lead scientist in the modern
vaccine
and she's awesome she's doing a science
communication processing her
social media as well and she has a
specifically targeted you know like
black communities and why she's helping
them
earn trust in the vaccines so
both you know developing trust in the
message but also being a trustee
messenger
are very important in this case i don't
know if you saw but this last week
the pope got his second dose of the
vaccine
and at least in colombia which is a
country that's very religious
the you know all these grand mass that
were not
even listening about the vaccine now
they're starting to listen about the
information because they saw
somebody that they having a very very
high esteem
take it um so it's just opening doors
for people to discuss and talk about
things that maybe they were super close
to talk about before well and this is
bill gates that as you might have seen
the fake news
there's like this super fake news saying
that bill gates is going to put
microchips in the vaccines
and that has been a big thing why people
don't want to get it
so you know you have both both things in
the balance like
if the messenger will help or maybe the
master will not help
um transmitting the message and for me
personally
what i've seen and what people have told
me after my video was like
they like to see a scientist that is
like very sick like
simple in a way like they are not seeing
me like as these super high scientists
that they cannot approach
but rather they see me like a normal
citizen that has
science education and might be able to
translate things that
maybe they cannot fully understand on
their own
so if you're talking to your family use
that you know as
as a health for you they love you and
they will listen to you if you are like
approaching them
in a nice and you know calm matter
and then the last thing is uh there's
this huge issue
of healing the trust of people in
science
uh actually yesterday i was in a small
workshop with the people from women in
acts science that i mentioned before
we were talking about this and i just
started writing down the the words that
they were
saying about the topic because i thought
it would make sense for today and they
were talking about you know
why is there distrust in science well
there's so many reasons like
society-wise there are reasons behind
that um
science itself is a process and
sometimes people
want the answers to be like right away
and like a hundred percent sure
and you all know that that's not always
the case so that sometimes generates
more uncertainty that certainty
uh but in general you know there are so
many things that are behind and i think
i think that even if each scientist in
the world decided to communicate their
science
a little bit more um you know it will be
a help
and in general will eventually reach to
a point where people will
feel more at least more able and more
willing to listen to scientists and what
they have to say
um and yeah and finally i was just going
to say there's a lot being done
especially
right now with the kobe vaccines i don't
know if you saw rob he's also a phd
student
at cornell i think he's biomed maybe
and something really similar happened to
him funny thing is that i had no idea of
his existence
until after my video came out and people
send me his
but he did something very similar he
just grabbed a board
and started explaining how the messenger
rna vaccines worked in a very simple
manner he's in english of course
uh because he wanted to tell his family
and it went super viral here as well
and there's other people talking about
this in spanish that's you know
what i've been mostly targeting for and
like looking for people that
um are doing something similar then you
know for example in colombia the
government started bringing up things
that were more useful
were more like an infographic and not
like a 90 page
word document that people were not going
to read
um and i've seen a lot of this in
english so i think that's also something
that you can share with your own family
if you feel like
um maybe you need some help when
explaining about this
but even though there's a lot being done
i think you know it's just something
that each one of us can do
um if we double check stuff
uh don't share absolutely everything we
receive fully read the things before we
share them
uh then we can eventually help
flatten this curve of misinformation and
also because
this whole experience made me realize
how much
impact our own publications can have
like
i literally just thought about my family
and it reached out like 200 000 people
so your own retweets on your own four
words or your own conversation with your
grandma
can make a huge difference in these and
other topics
uh so yeah i was just wanted to use this
last slide to
to say that and to hopefully inspire you
a little bit to talk about this and
other topics
with people that want to talk about them
uh yeah so that's just like how my
profile looks now after all this
experience
uh you can go there if you if if you
want to follow
but aside from that i think it will be
interesting if we can talk a little bit
wait i think we have some minutes so if
people want to
say things in the chat or just like
speak up or tristan if you want to say
something that will be
also cool
that was an excellent talk i think we
should all give juliana a round of
applause
thank you virtually or through icons
i think juliana you're a natural at
giving the first
presentation thanks yes
thank you um thank you touched on
um a topic that i feel
strongly about it and that is it's
our responsibility to
talk science to non-scientists
and to find ways of doing that you know
kovis
is very serious but um
biology is serious and
we have to have a basic
uh level of understanding
in order for the general population
to appreciate the gravity
of a pandemic for example
yeah yeah absolutely agree on that
yeah early in your presentation you made
the point about how
uh how israel sort of primed a lot of
their population
with information about kobe to get them
ready to talk about
the vaccine and sometimes i forget that
it can take some time for
information like correct information to
be absorbed by a population
i keep thinking that like the vaccine
will come out and they're like oh i can
just tell people about
it then and then they'll believe me
what's happening takes time
yeah it takes time and people also want
to like
see it in different places you know like
not only you telling them but maybe you
are like the first step they take
towards understanding a topic uh so for
example my mom after we talked about
this she
every like couple of days she has been
sending me more stuff she's like oh i
saw this
and like on her own she's like educating
herself on the topic and i think that's
a huge win that people like
maybe not for covid but later on they
really want to understand science
and biology and on their own they will
start reading and looking for places to
understand that a little bit more
hey juliana very nice how are you
thank you good i i just wondered uh you
may have mentioned in your talk but i
wondered if you've had a chance to
connect with cornell alliance for
science
uh because they're oh you have that's
good because no no i haven't
but i had it in my mind good because
there's a lot of commonality
uh between what you're talking about
here and they they have some really
splendid
uh educational materials resources that
they're developing
uh for some of these very topics so it
if you get a chance
i i i'm really engaging with that uh
with that group
that's all i wanted to say but wonderful
presentation
oh thank you yeah thank you for the
advice
what do you think tristan oh go ahead i
have a question
julie hi adam um hey
um so do you have any plans to start
producing videos
on like uh you know topics in plant
pathology for example
yeah so at first i thought all these
people that
were starting to ask me questions were
only interested about
covid and i was a little bummed like oh
i don't want to keep talking about code
forever but
i've realized that they are interested
in everything and they actually started
asking me like what exactly do you do
so i started telling like i work with
plants that get sick
and you know making short videos about
that showing how
symptoms look like and there's a lot of
interest out there
so of course i mean i'm a phd student i
don't have
so many times that other science
communicators have to talk and do
videos and do stuff but yeah i'll
definitely try to start doing things
i was thinking you know all these people
if we can explain them
very simple things like crispr for
example but in a simple term
it will be very nice uh for them to get
that type of
information so yeah hopefully awesome
yeah
great thanks
i just wanted to comment a little not so
much on the topic but on our method of
this
luncheon is i really liked the polls
that you
had that allowed us to interact
like while you were talking but i think
if anybody else has opinions on how to
get everyone who's currently on the sim
call
more engaged yeah
looking for those inputs as well yeah
that will be nice this was an experiment
as
gillian said so it's nice to have more
ideas
yeah we'll have another trial again in
april
and i think we might make a few changes
but i like how things are going getting
close to
115.
uh so if there are no more questions
i think this would be a good stopping
point
yeah sounds good thanks everyone for
joining us
thank you thank you
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web
at cornell.edu